esta vez tenemos la ecuación diferencial
de 7x igual a 3 james y queremos
encontrar la solución particular que nos
debe de de igual a 2 cuando x es igual a
1 así que los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y vean se pueden encontrar esto
por su cuenta muy bien ahora vamos a
trabajarlo juntos algunos de ustedes
podrían decir inmediatamente oye yo
reconozco esta forma de una ecuación
diferencial ahí la solución va a ser un
exponencial y ustedes estarán en lo
correcto pero no voy a ir directo a eso
solo voy a reconocer que esta es una
ecuación diferencial separable y con
esto voy a resolverlo de esa manera
entonces cuando digo que es separable
eso significa que puedo separar todas
las 10 leyes de un lado y todas las
equis y de x del otro lado así que lo
que puedo hacer es dividir de ambos
lados de esta ecuación entre james y
multiplicar de ambos lados por de x y
justo así obtendrían que bueno me queda
1 entre james de james es igual a 3
de x
ahora observa tanto del lado izquierdo
como del lado derecho tengo todo listo
para poder integrar de esto es lo que la
gente habla cuando dicen ecuación
diferencial separable así que vamos a
integrar del lado izquierdo y si lo
quiero escribir de una forma bastante
general podré escribir que la anti
derivada de 1 entre james va a ser igual
a logaritmo natural del valor absoluto
de james aquí estoy sacando el anti
derivada con respecto a y ahora podrían
agregar una constante pero no voy a
agregarla y solamente voy a agregar una
sola en el lado derecho podría agregarla
solamente de un lado entonces esto va a
ser igual y tengo la anti derivada de m3
de x lo cual es simplemente 3x ya que se
agregará la constante prometida y ahora
vamos a pensar de un poco bien ahora
vamos a volver a escribir esto pero de
una forma exponencial
entonces nos quedaría que el valor
absoluto de james va a ser igual
elevado a la 3x más se podría escribir
que es elevado a la 3 x c lo puedo ver
como el elevado a la 3x por el elevado a
la c donde he elevado la se ha observado
va a ser una constante arbitraria así
que vamos a ponerle un nombre le voy a
poner el nombre de c mayúscula y bueno
ya sé que vamos a obtener valores
diferentes para estas es pero solamente
estamos tratando de dar un sentido
general de cómo se vería la estructura
de esta ecuación diferencial entonces ha
elevado la sep se va a llamar ser y
ahora podríamos decir que esto va a ser
una constante por el elevado la 3x ojo
esto aún no es una función estamos
tratando de encontrar esta función
solución para esta ecuación diferencial
entonces esto de aquí lo que nos está
diciendo es que o que es igual a una
constante por el elevado a la 3x
y es igual a menos la constante que
multiplica ha elevado a la 3x esto para
quitar el valor absoluto bien hasta
ahorita no sabemos quién es justo eso es
lo que queremos entonces lo que podemos
hacer es escoger una de estas dos
ecuaciones y luego despejar hace
suponiendo que estamos en alguna de
estas dos así que voy a escoger quién
igual hace porque a la 3x y entonces
veremos si podemos cumplir estas
restricciones recuerda y es igual a 2
cuando x es igual a 1 cuando james es
igual a c que multiplica ha elevado la
3x esencialmente vamos a tomar esta otra
consideración entonces vamos a
escribirlo cuando x es igual a 1 y es
igual a 2 así que lo podemos ver así 2
que bueno sabemos que es lo que vale
james es igual a c que multiplica a en
elevado a la 3 por equis pero en este
caso donde hay es igual a 2x vale 1
entonces a la 3 por 1
y bueno nos queda que 2 es igual a c por
el elevado la 3 y entonces para resolver
así podríamos dividir de ambos lados
entre el elevado la 3 o podría
multiplicar de ambos lados por el
elevado al menos 3 en lo mismo y así
obtengo que se es igual a 2 por el
elevado a la menos 3 eso es igual a cero
entonces ahora vamos a sustituirlo en
nuestra solución particular y ahora sí
que nos quedaría que james es igual a 0
cm es lo mismo que dos por ea la menos
tres por el elevado a la 3x
ahora estoy sacando el producto de dos
cosas que tienen la misma base entonces
puedo sumar los exponentes para que
quede mucho más limpio y me quedaría que
james es igual a 2 por el elevado a la
3x y voy a sumar los exponentes menos 3
y ahí lo tienen esta es una manera en la
que podrán escribir una solución
particular que cumple estas
restricciones y es igual a 2 cuando x es
igual a 1 para esta ecuación diferencial
separable